well that's a portion of one of the most
popular TED talks delivered by social
scientists and best-selling author brené
Brown the 2010 discussion about the
power of vulnerability is the fourth
most viewed TED talk of all time get
this and has been viewed 31 million
times
I believe it Brown has spent more than a
decade studying vulnerability courage
shame and empathy the Houston resident
recently was stood withstood rather
Hurricane Harvey's path and aided her
neighbors today she's out with a new
book it's called braving the wilderness
the quest for true belonging and the
courage to stand alone Brown writes this
true belonging doesn't require you to
change who you are it requires you to be
who you are
Rene Brown joins us at the table good
morning to you brené Brown good morning
good morning I'm fascinated by your
title with the quest for true belonging
and the courage to stand alone because
those to me are two competing ideas yet
you say they're both important yeah and
the research took me by surprise I
thought belonging is something we
negotiate externally with groups of
people I want to belong with this but as
it turns out men and women who have the
deepest sense of true belonging are
people who also have the courage to
stand alone when called to do that they
are willing to maintain their integrity
and risk disconnection in order to stand
up for what they believe in
are there no circumstances in which you
wouldn't want to change who you are no
you know it was crazy for me is guess
what emerged as the greatest barrier to
belonging fitting in yeah because when
we fit in we assess a situation and we
acclimate when we belong we bring
ourselves to it and say this is who I am
and so real belonging requires us to be
authentically ourselves and very
difficult in this polarized environment
growth is a part of everyone's life but
growth is a part of everyone and so it's
not about not ever changing who you are
it's about changing to be accepted
that's a charge you keep saying but you
say though that nowadays we're turning
away from each other this is what I
think is so fascinating we're turning
away from each other we're going to
blame and rage and that when we do that
blame and rage becomes anger and that's
all part of the pain that we
all experiencing that's fear fear leads
to terrorism you're saying that we're
all deeply afraid you know one of the
one of the big other big shocks I guess
from the research for me was looking at
these two tracts of research that we see
emerging and across the world globally
one is we are more sorted than we have
ever been in the history of the u.s. we
have built ideological bunkers we are
more likely now to live with worship
with and go to school with people who
are politically and ideologically
like-minded you would think a natural
result of sorting ourselves into these
factions would be closer ties more
connection but as it turns out as
sorting grows so does loneliness
so we're becoming more lonely as we're
becoming more balkanized
it seems to apply not only to that also
but what do you read what you watch what
you hear everything it's its ideological
bunkers and echo chambers but what's
interesting about what happens behind
those is it's not it's counterfeit
connection it's not real connection all
it is I call it common enemy intimacy
the only thing we have in common is we
hate the same people yeah you worried
about holding hands with strangers yeah
explain what you mean well one of the
things that emerged is that a belief an
inextricable human connection is a
fundamental part of belonging to believe
that we are inextricably tied to one
another that that is not breakable but
it is forgettable we can forget at times
I mean as a Houstonian mm-hmm we were
just massively reminded there was no one
my husband was in a kayak pulling
neighbors out of their house there was
at no time did I see I was in the
shelter do people say I'll help you what
are you which a political belief who did
you vote for we need to hold hands with
strangers we need reminders collective
joy and pain reminders that we are
inextricably connected to each other by
something greater than us and we need
that on a daily basis whether it's music
or concerts or disaster relief we need
those moment that's not what we're
seeing you said you talked about
dehumanization that that's what you see
a lot of people doing now I think
dehumanization first of all
dehumanization is it
center of every genocide in recorded
history and every genocide starts with
dehumanization and dehumanization is a
very subtle process it is about moving a
group of people because we're hardwired
to not be able to hurt each other
we are hardwired neurobiologically to
not be able to kill rape torture beat
each other so in order to be able to do
that we have to slowly move groups of
people out of what we consider moral
inclusion we have to move them out of
what we see as humanity and do you know
where that starts consistently over heat
over history
it starts with language and if you go on
Twitter today our Facebook or any social
we see people on the left and right
using dehumanizing language free about
each other like that and it is
terrifying and I think in the end it
can't be are you conservative or liberal
right or left
are you dehumanizing are you not we
should all be equally offended by that
regardless of who the target is it's so
easy to say let's all get along but
we're not I mean and so you could say
one sentence on what we could do to
change it and I know it's more than one
sentence mm-hmm but you're a good talker
burning give us is in I'm not short on
the talk I think one sentence is we are
connected to each other in a profound
way and the thing that moves us away
from that faster than anything else is
not politics but fear mmm I could talk
to you all day around thank you so much
here I am